considera la siguiente función por
pedazos y nos dan una función
efe dt que está definida en tres partes
la primera está cuadrada menos 5 t
cuando t es menor o igual que menos 10
vale temas 19 cuando t es mayor que
menos 10 y menor que menos 2 y te kubica
entre temas nueve cuando t es mayor o
igual que menos dos la pregunta es cuál
es el valor de f evaluada en menos 10
muy bien entonces esencialmente aquí nos
están diciendo cuál valor de t es el que
tenemos que utilizar verdad tenemos que
tomarte igual a menos 10 así que eso
corresponde justamente a este caso que
tenemos aquí verdad este está incluyendo
el caso en el que te vale menos 10
entonces tenemos que usar esta regla de
correspondencia verdad eso nos dice que
f de menos 10 tiene que ser igual a
menos 10 al cuadrado simplemente
sustituimos menos 10 cada vez que
observamos un ante tenemos menos 10 al
cuadra
-5 porte que en este caso es menos 10
entonces menos 10 al cuadrado es 100 y
menos 5 x menos 10 es justamente más 50
verdad menos por menos nos da más y 5
por 10 nos da 50 y finalmente 100 más 50
es 150 entonces 150 es el valor de f de
menos 10 vamos con otro ejercicio dice
considera la siguiente función por
pedazos y ahora nos dan hdx definida en
tres partes x kubica cuando x está entre
menos infinito y 0 24 entre x menos uno
cuando x está entre 0 y 8 y x menos 1
por x 3 cuando x está entre 8 e infinito
cuál es el valor de h evaluada en
-3 entonces es el mismo caso que
teníamos anteriormente verdad tenemos
que encontrar en cuál de estos
intervalos se encuentra menos 3 y
justamente se encuentra en esta verdad
el número menos 3 es más chico que 0
verdad así que le corresponde esta regla
tendríamos que evaluar menos 3 al cubo
si nos hubieran preguntado por ejemplo h
evaluada en 3 entonces hubiéramos usado
esta regla que tenemos en medio y si nos
hubieran dicho h evaluada en 30
hubiéramos utilizado esta última regla
que tenemos así que vamos a resolver
este problema fácilmente h evaluada en
menos 3 es justamente menos 3 elevado al
cubo y menos 3 elevado al cubo será
menos 27 verdad 3 al cubo es 27 y menos
x menos por menos es más
así que esencialmente podemos ignorar
las otras dos posibilidades vamos con un
último ejercicio este es un poco
distinto dice se tiene la gráfica de gx
digamos que esta es la gráfica de gx
relaciona cada expresión con su valor y
nos dan una tabla en donde hay que
evaluar la función g en ciertos valores
y nos dan posibilidades puede valer 37
menos 3 o quizás indefinido vamos a ver
qué pasa con g evaluado en menos 3.000 1
entonces si nos vamos a la gráfica menos
3.001 anda digamos como por aquí verdad
está un poco más a la izquierda de 3 si
nos fijamos en el valor que toma la
función sería justamente el valor de 3
verdad esta función está definida por
pedazos y así se ve la gráfica pero en
menos 3.000 1 vale 3 así que vamos a
rellenar este circuito
qué pasa con g evaluado en 3.999 3.99 es
casi 4 verdad casi 4 casi 4 no es
precisamente 4 así que está ligeramente
a la izquierda y entonces podemos
observar ahora que el valor de la
función en 3.999 es 7 verdad entonces
este es el valor de la función en 3.999
que pasa cuando tenemos que evaluada en
4.000 uno bueno estamos ligeramente a la
derecha del 4 verdad y en la función
evaluada en 4 nos dice que vale 7 verdad
y eso lo podemos ver con este círculo
relleno sin embargo al movernos tantito
a la derecha del 4 ya no tenemos el
valor 7 sino ahora cae hacia abajo y
tenemos el valor de menos 3 cuando
estamos ligeramente a la derecha de 4
entonces el valor d
en 4.000 uno sería menos tres verdad y
finalmente cuánto vale que en nueve
bueno pues nos vamos a nueve y vemos que
bueno quizás estaríamos tentados a decir
que también es menos 3 sin embargo en el
9 hay una bolita abierta eso significa
que la función en 9 no toma este valor y
de hecho no vemos ningún valor que pueda
tomar la función verdad si tomar algún
valor veríamos digamos como un circulito
sin embargo no hay ninguno así que esta
función está indefinida en 9